To find out what c needs to equal to make this equation true, we have to modify
both sides of the equation so we get c by itself on one side of the equal sign,
and everything else on the other side. Now, to insure that both sides of the
equation actually remain equal to each other, so that we can legally continue to
write equal signs in our equation, whatever we do to one side of the equation,
we need to do to the other side as well. If these two things start out having
the same value, but I, for example, add 4 to the left side and subtract 1 from
the right side, then they can't possible equal to one another anymore, since
I've changed them in different ways. We'll do plenty of practice with that
concept in the coming lessons. For now though, let's think about what's
preventing c from being by itself. We know that we want our final equation to
look like c equals blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, something. So, it means we need
to isolate c as my petitions like to say. Instead of having just c though, we
have 92 times c. Remember, there's an invisible multiplication sign right here
between our coefficient and our variable. We basically need to undo this
multiplication, get rid of it, and the way to undo multiplication is to do some
division. Since right now, c is being multiplied by 92, to have just c on its
own, we need to divide by 92. But that also means, since I'm dividing on one
side of the equation that I also need to divide on the other side. So, I also
need to divide 598 by 92. Looking at the right side, 92c over 92 is, as we
wished, just c. And on the left side, 598 divided by 92 is equal to the number 6
and a half. Just to be safe, it's always a good idea to check your answer if you
know how to. In this case, we can just use substitution. Starting with our
initial equation, 598 equals 92c, we can plug in our new value for c and see if
this makes a true equation.